it shut down the world and killed
hundreds of thousands of people a virus
that has affected every country and
forced us to reassess our lives but out
of the crisis have come lessons and a
chance to improve our scientific
knowledge
tonight on Sky News our medical life
after the pandemic and our new world
[Music]
a very good evening I'm jarred Monahan
and over the course of this week I've
been speaking to some of the greatest
minds in politics business culture and
tonight science joining us again tonight
a new live virtual studio audience from
all around the world will be asking
questions about how we can build a new
future look at the wave looking forward
to hearing your questions now facing
them the director of the Wellcome Trust
and a member of the government Sage
committee Sir Jeremy Barra
who also got the former commissioner of
the US Food and Drug Administration the
FDA dr. Margaret Hamburg very good to
have you joining them dr. John and kanga
song director of the Africa Centers for
Disease Control and our quartet is
completed with Professor Dame Sally
Davis the former chief medical officer
for England welcome or so with a world
forced to confront the biggest health
crisis in generations tonight we look at
the future at science and medicine
[Music]
the coronavirus has hit the UK one
British man who likely contracted a
virus in Singapore he then travelled to
a French ski resort then returned from
France to the UK you don't know the
source of the outbreak and we don't
understand its severity
the first confirmed death in Britain
from coronavirus stay at home protect
our NHS and save lives this used to be a
theater just how much has been canceled
and sacrificed
my wife into allowed to come with me
anymore
miserably these NHS workers who lost
their lives were all at a greater risk
as a community we are put at risk every
single day for a mother than to not be
able to grieve it's unimaginable and how
those deaths holes have grown
world health organization now says the
corona virus outbreak is a pandemic NHS
staff are risking their own safety I
understand people's anxieties on the
front line
don't do something really quickly for
the pair Oh God look deep there aren't
gonna die they want to discharge people
but we don't want to test it sometimes
I'll sit in the bar or not I'll cry the
Prime Minister has been taken into an
intensive care unit the NHS has saved my
life Lucas
[Applause]
this is a very easy way of for me to
support the cause
this is probably the biggest step
forward since the crisis began
government wants to rely on
self-reporting rather than tests the
world's health system Xander our view of
the science behind them tested to the
limits so let's dive straight in let's
get our first question from our audience
tonight this comes from Lindsey Forbes
who's on the Koster blanket in Spain
good evening Lindsey please kick us off
with your question good evening darling
good evening panel my question is this
will there be a effective vaccine or is
it more likely that we'll need to find
effective medical treatments as was the
case with HIV I have another reason for
asking this question the one of these an
effective vaccine but the fatality rate
for the old and compromised it's
frightening lehigh we need better
treatments as soon as possible
so that people are no more worried about
catching calls it than they are about
catching the suit ok so right into the
meat of it vaccines and short of that a
treatment or treatments let's kick off
with said Jeremy Farah then and a very
good evening to you well let's talk
about vaccines first of all we hear
about these well I suppose they're up
into the three figures of testing and
trials and development going on and some
of them are handful a large handful are
now in human trials are you confident
we're going to get a vaccine soon yes
what soon means I don't know and I think
the question that's come is is
absolutely the right question to ask I
was a junior doctor at the start of the
HIV epidemic in the mid 1980s and of
course at that time we also thought we
would have a vaccine I spend a lot of my
life working on tuberculosis and malaria
and the truth is we still don't have
vaccines for those diseases either we
cannot put all
our hopes on a vaccine yes I'm
optimistic yes the science is
progressing incredibly quickly all
around the world including here in the
UK but we cannot assume we'll have a
vaccine we don't know when we'll have it
and we don't know when it'll be
accessible to everybody who needs it
wherever they are in the world so the
question is really well posed that we
also have to push on with research on
Diagnostics so that we can make
diagnosis quicker and we also have to
press on we're trying to treat so that
we we develop drugs that can both
prevent this infection and if you are
unlucky enough to catch it that we can
prevent you getting more sick going into
hospital and tragically dying so we have
to do all of those as well as the social
science and we cannot assume that any
one of those will deliver what we need
for this infection what dr. Hamburg I
saw you agreeing with Sir Jeremy about a
vaccine hope for it but it can't depend
upon it so let's talk more about those
treatments and because you're in the
United States we've heard a lot from
President Trump about treatments like
the anti malarial one hydroxychloroquine
even bleach well leave the second one
out but could there be a repurpose drug
out there well it's very important that
we move forward on all tracks and that
we harness the best possible science
wherever it is to advance our forward
movement towards both drugs and vaccines
with respect to drugs there are a number
of different strategies that are
underway finding an old drug that can be
repurposed for the treatment of this
novel coronavirus and kovat 19 the
disease it causes would certainly be one
approach and it would be quicker because
those drugs already exist and we know a
lot about both their safety in in humans
and we know a fair bit about their
mechanisms of action in many cases but
most likely the drugs that will really
prove most beneficial will be ones that
will be developed specifically to
address this particular corona virus and
our understanding of how the virus
causes disease and people and
immune system responds to the disease
but those drugs are going to take longer
and we also have to recognize that just
like with hiv/aids we probably won't
just have one drug that will do the
trick we will probably have a
combination of drugs that will help us
to interrupt various critical points in
the life cycle of this virus and also
how our body responds to it so I think
that you know we're looking at at
long-term efforts but we may have some
things that will provide some benefit
sooner rather than later and we're
beginning to see that happening and of
course the goal is also to have
treatments that can be used outside of a
clinical care setting to treat and
prevent limit the symptoms and the
course just like with flu we have an
antiviral drug that can help us to
reduce the course of the disease the
seriousness of the symptoms so that it
becomes much more manageable okay well
listen I'm gonna talk to our other two
panelists in a moment or two but I just
want to bring in our audience here so
some of you nodding along there as you
were hearing those opening comments from
Sir Jeremy and dr. Hamburg and I want to
ask you can you take part in a straw
poll for us we've been doing these every
evening it's just a show of hands
it's just indicative but it's about a
vaccine we heard Lindsey saying how
important that is and short of that some
kind of effective treatment so I want to
ask you by show of hands how comfortable
will you be returning to something like
normal life if no effective vaccine is
developed so there's no vaccine will you
be happy returning to something
approaching your normal life put your
hands up if you would well maybe maybe
half something like that with no vaccine
but hopefully some treatments along the
way well let's feed that then into our
discussion and Dame Sally a vaccine is
it's that then the icing on the cake
our treatments out there that you think
can help and indeed things like have
been mentioned during the course of this
virus vitamin D and tobacco patches I
don't think there's any proof of any of
those as yet and I wouldn't recommend
nicotine patches as they are used for
stopping smoking nicotine is addictive I
do think that we have to remember that
we in Britain and across the world have
been flattening the curve as people talk
about it
by infection prevention and control by
washing our hands properly by I hate
this one respiratory etiquette you know
blowing your nose being careful not
coffee on people many people using masks
so they don't transmit and actually the
lockdown protecting the vulnerable by
staying safe and so that will remain the
backbone and there are many other
advantages to exactly that to taking
these infection prevention and control
efforts our flu season this year
finished early because we were so
successful we will get fewer bacterial
infections as well we will see fewer
infections in general that'll keep
people well and out of the NHS so while
we wait for all this hard work from
laboratories and scientists don't forget
we have a major role to play doctor and
Kangas on very good evening to you and
can I ask you from the African
perspective how high up the agenda of
vaccine development is one fork ovid 19
presumably it will be more used to
Africa to get one for something like
malaria absolutely the continent as a
whole is extremely engaged and concerned
with issues related to access to
coverage 19 vaccines when they
subsequently become available we just
were a part of the dose who signed a
declaration that was published in
financial times just horribly they're
calling for people's backs in
which means we are mindful of the fact
that access to vaccines when they become
available is critical for a continent of
1.2 billion people we always remind
ourselves of what happened in 1996 when
HIV antiretroviral treatment was
available they took so many years before
he became available on the continent of
Africa and so many lives were lost due
to that so incontinence extreme mind
were concerned with that the Africa
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention and Africa Commission Union
Commission convenient meeting in extra
fees to continue to have a dialogue on
access to vaccines when become a unhear
concern the entire spectrum of vaccine
developed that the conference you play
an active role in facts in research and
development as well as clinical trials
not just be a passive recipients of dr.
Hamburg I want to ask you about that
about availability of a vaccine if one
is developed and you heard their doctor
and kanga song saying how crucial it is
that Africa would have access to one but
some indications coming from President
Trump that if there were one develops it
would be once again I was in so many
things with the president America first
well certainly he has indicated great
concern about making sure that we move
forward as quickly as possible to
develop a vaccine and we make sure that
we have manufacturing capacity here in
the US it's crucial that he and our
leadership in this country understand
though that this is a global pandemic
and that our safety as a nation depends
also on addressing this problem wherever
else it is in the world it's also
crucial that we appreciate the fact that
science is a global enterprise that
collaborations with scientists around
the world and working to advance vaccine
research and development is going to be
a collaborative process and we will do
better and we will end up with more
opportunities to have a vaccine that's
safe and effective and more
opportunities to manufacture in large
numbers if again we work collaboratively
moreover studying this vaccine is
probably going to require an
international effort because this
outbreak this epidemic and pandemic is
moving to different places around the
world and you needed large populations
to study it so while we sadly have many
many cases now in the US and lead the
world in that you know we may not be
able to only study it in our country if
we in fact continue to make progress at
reducing the disease and finally we
don't know where the first vaccines are
gonna successfully be developed and
cross the finish line into the
marketplace for use and we don't know
whether any of the efforts in any one
country will be ultimately successful so
again even if you're thinking selfishly
about your own citizens you need to be
thinking globally and engaging as well
because access to something developed
somewhere else may actually prove
critical for the protection of citizens
so we are hoping okay as we always have
in the past that the US will provide
critical leadership for developing the
science and technology needed to get one
hopefully more than one successful
vaccine produced in this country but
that we will do it in a spirit of
engagement and collaborative concern
about creating a safety net around the
world through vaccine protection and
really a global effort and collaboration
is something there going to be the
course of this evening but I want to get
to our next question or another vital
question coming up from our virtual
audience so this from David Henderson
David I know you're in Guildford in
Surrey would you please put your
question to the panel yeah good evening
donuts and distinguished panel do you
believe that we still run a serious risk
of a
second wave or a future mutation of
kovat 19 medical coding 20 later this
year and if so are we but that I mean
the government and their agencies
prepared or preparing for such an
eventuality and what might have been
done differently in the present crisis
okay
Kovac 20 the second wave much discussed
much feared of course and while we're
all waves doctor and kanga song I want
to ask you first of all about how Africa
has dealt and is dealing with the first
wave much comment being made there were
fears before it came the what affected
Africa you could see it coming there
were many fears because of the state of
health systems that it would really
wreak havoc with in in many African
countries and at this point it doesn't
seem to have been the case I think we
should be extremely careful when we look
at in numbers and interpret that our
numbers in Africa us us of this evident
the continent has reported about 157,000
cases and that is up from last week
about 30 percent so the pandemic in
Africa delayed because we took very
early measures I mean in terms of
coordinating our actions at the highest
level of the continent and then sleep on
the countries went to lock down very
quickly and shut down movement and the
economies but now they are being to
unlock that and we see that there this
is steady increase in the number of
cases over the last couple of weeks and
that's also true the number of deaths we
are at about 4,500 deaths reported
across 24 countries on the continent so
it is a delayed funding big and there's
absolutely no doubt that is gaining
momentum so we should absolutely be very
very careful with that
unfortunately intensified efforts the
other thing we should remember is that
our testing capacity is develop if you
compared Africa a continent of 1.2
billion people and then you square that
number of tests we
conductor is really very limited
conducted about 1600 tests bail million
people so if you compare that to the
number of tests being conducted in the
UK and other United States is literally
it requires a lot of efforts there so
again when we interpret the numbers and
the continent we should really
understand that we need to expand a
testing as much as possible and that's
why we have launched an initiative core
part the partnership to accelerate copy
person on the continent to increase that
number of testing to us at least to a
million to 20 million then legs come in
three months so that well is allow us to
be ahead of abundant soon again is a
word portion that the continent they
delayed from the big because we observe
it happening in China in Europe and the
United States the first cases were
reported on the continent around for
fascinating insights thank you very much
indeed for that and Sir Jeremy second
wave of Kovach 19 and should we also be
preparing it was contained in the
question from David there as well we we
learned today I'm sure you've known
about it for an awful long time
something like 1.7 million viruses in
animals that could potentially get into
humans we've got to be worried about
them haven't we yeah we do of course and
and I'll come to that in a second
because we've got to worry about kovat
19 at the moment or Kobe 20 as it's just
been called I think at the moment of
course UK is still in its first wave as
we've just heard from John Africa is
just starting to go into its first wave
and much of Europe thankfully is coming
off the peak of that first wave but I
think at the moment we have to plan and
we have to assume that a second wave is
coming
Sally Dame Sally said earlier the
lockdowns
the hand-washing the physical distancing
the care for the vulnerable has
suppressed this virus and it's
suppressed it the numbers are coming
thankfully finally but it's not changed
the fundamental biology it's not changed
the fundamental way this virus goes
between me and you the transmission so
we've suppressed it but we haven't got
rid of it and this is now a human
endemic infection in my view and in the
UK and in much of the world actually
only about 6 or 8 percent of people have
seen this infection and we hope are
amused and that means that over 90% of
people have not seen yet this infection
and are probably still susceptible to it
so the vast majority of every population
in every country in the world remains
susceptible to another infection so if
this does come back in a second wave
many of us and I think myself included
would still be at risk of getting
infected and that is the coming of a
second wave and more countries all over
the world have got to do is learn
lessons from the first wave put in place
things that you know we didn't get right
in the first way we should admit that
and make sure that when we come into the
autumn and the winter of this year when
other infections influenza will be
circulating as well we have everything
we need in place so that we can reduce
the impacts of that second wave and that
is what we should all be planning for at
the moment and we should not
underestimate the power of this virus to
come back in a second wave professor
Davis what are your thoughts on that
some say it could go go v19 could go the
way of SARS or MERS other coronaviruses
that seem to to disappear and not come
back well so far the countries that seem
to have got rid of it then still have
cases popping up and while it's rattling
round and round the world that'll be
very difficult if you think about flu it
is in the northern hemisphere then it
goes to the southern it may mutate but
then it comes back round and it just
goes round year after year with
different strains and different changes
I absolutely agree with Sir Jeremy it's
not gone away in Britain we need to
continue with the planning
and the work that's happening because
though I'm not a forecaster or a modeler
I would prefer to be prepared for a
second wave and even maybe a third wave
when we look back at 2009 10 the mild
flu pandemic we have three waves and so
we can expect more of this the question
is is it a big wave or is it because of
the way we handle it lots of little
waves it'll go on until we are immune
well let's so reveal some of our polling
all week we've been revealing the
results of a wide-ranging opinion poll
that we conducted for these programs
about the future facing the world now
this is one of the questions we asked
will the pandemic lead to health
services in Britain getting better or
worse and these are the results 43% of
those survey tell us they thought health
services would be better eight percent
thought they would get worse than thirty
four percent thought there wouldn't be
much difference 15 percent said they
actually didn't know I didn't have an
opinion on it so will health services
improve after the pandemic let's bring
in a member of the virtual audience so
once again somebody with some expertise
in this area or Wendy Noble is a doctor
working in Dubai very good to talk to
you Wendy and what is your question
hello good evening Palin my question is
is when and how are we going to address
the hard question of managing those
people and in the population who persist
in unhealthy living practices that
promote ill health such as obesity and
smoking both of these cost our NHS a
huge amount of money and we don't have
unlimited finances and in fact now
they're getting slimmer by the day so
how are we gonna provide medical care
especially after the pandemic okay a
very good question I'm going to put some
of those thoughts to panel a sorry to
our audience sir for a show of hands in
a moment or two but let's just address
that question and indeed the original
polling then dr. Hamburg there are a lot
of people thinking in actual fact health
services where
improve but given the stresses and
strains they're under from coronavirus
and then the the more long-term strains
of things like an obesity crisis can
they really improve well this is going
to be a very challenging time for health
as we move through this coded crisis to
whatever new normalcy we have and of
course getting through the decoded
crisis is our current and acute
challenge for the medical care system
and for all of us but but I think we
need to really think long and hard about
this and and really recommit to making
sure that we can provide the care that
is needed for people on a routine basis
and in a situation of crisis our system
of health care in the u.s. is of course
very different than what you have in the
UK and frankly in a situation like this
and at other times I have often looked
with admiration to the UK system because
it is more coherent and it really is a
system where are whereas ours is very
fragmented and there are many more
people who can fall through the cracks
but I think that we have learned in this
country and I think other countries have
learned as well about the importance of
doing a number of things as we think
about how to promote health and and
prevent disease even in a situation like
this one is we need to make sure that
our our health care systems our clinics
and our hospitals are adequately
equipped and that our health care
workers have what they need the tools
they need to be able to do their job and
it's been painful for us to watch our
frontline health care workers have to go
in and take care of kovat 19 patients
without the personal protective gear
that they needed without the ventilators
for support without even the tests that
they needed to be able to assess
patients and manage their care but it's
also been
call to see how our system has not
really supported patients to be as
robust in their health as the questioner
was asking as they were forced now to
address this additional health crisis
and without a doubt some of the most
vulnerable patients for kovat are those
that have other underlying medical
conditions chronic conditions like
obesity and diabetes and hypertension
certainly add considerably to the risk
and I hope we will go back and recommit
to making sure that we can provide care
I think we've also learned a lot about
how to use non-traditional tools of care
telemedicine and home-based care and
digital tools and we need to integrate
those into our ongoing healthcare as
well so I think healthcare will look
different as we move forward hopefully
it in many ways will serve patients
better and it will also focus more on
prevention and not so much on treating
problems once they are wrenched well
that's the perspective from the peak of
the developed world what about the
developing world doctor and kanga song
we know that in some countries in Africa
health services very stretched pretty
pretty scarce - a lot of people what do
you think then about the issue of
rationing perhaps
so besides Kobe know before copied the
continent was already challenged with
multiple diseases HIV tuberculosis
malaria and the rising rates of non
communicable diseases diabetes
hypertension and challenges due to
access to immunization so Kobe has
further compounded and will continue to
make those situations look extremely
difficult and so our cell systems are
fragile we will manage in and stop in to
build a cell system then they copy now
we've learned a lot from West Africa
during the previous Ebola outbreak where
11,000 people died
and we learned that many people died
because I don't asleep because of a
beloved because of the the effect of
Ebola on the health system so we are
extremely concerned what happened to a
very fragile heart systems in the
presence of hope as we speak today who
he's dealing a new outbreak of people we
just have Julian Singh we had an
untrained blood outfit which we have
working very hard with the World Health
Organization and the company opted for
that first of all the first two and half
years we have in the same country issues
related to outfits of missiles kurta and
a laser the co-contraction
compounds a huge number of orders per
drop and Christ that we're dealing there
so we really need to step back and have
a comprehensive discussion as to what
they are strategy as a continent to
build a person and considered that truly
our economy and hurt investment and
honestly a cost to defend that in a
boardvision who need to develop for the
continent in order to get rid of these
fragments okay well we've got to
somebody else who's got some input I'm
sure on this and that is of course is
our our questioner let's go back to
Wendy as I say a doctor working there in
Dubai and Wendy to put your own question
to you what's your view on it in terms
of those who persist in unhealthy living
practices which promote ill health such
as obesity and smoking are they less
deserving then of precious and scarce
health resources I don't think you can
say that because that's not actually a
humane or sensible way of going forward
and these people are actually
deserving of healthcare just like
everybody else but I am here in Dubai
where obesity and smoking are huge
issues with a large proportion of the
population here being diabetic
now obesity worldwide is an enormous Lee
burgeoning problem and one of the
problem
the things that support it the fast food
and the rest of it are actually a major
problem we've seen queue stretching down
to the other side of the town
practically on the television from
McDonald's you know images from the UK
and we had the same thing here I mean so
different but it's interesting I wonder
whether the lack of fast food in the
last few weeks has actually contributed
to better health maybe I don't know when
nobody's obviously studying that they're
too busy looking after Kovac indeed we
know sorry we know sorry Wendy
I want to involve you and indeed the
other 49 members of our audience to stay
on this very subject what a what an
interesting debate it is and I want to
take another of these straw polls a show
of hands is all we require and I want to
put this question to you should there be
financial penalties or maybe
restrictions of health services to pay
for the care of those who put their own
health at risk through smoking or
overeating
for example raise your hand if you think
people should have to pay for something
like that what do you think hmm well
certainly certainly over a third and
probably less than a half thank you very
much indeed for that swell let's throw
that into the debate and Sir Jeremy then
and back to kovat I mean Co vid 19 has
given us a public health message we've
seen that in the mortality figures have
we in particularly when it comes to
obese people and people who develop type
2 diabetes as a result of their obesity
they are more at risk yeah they are as
are the elderly you know I really get
worried when I when I hear ideas that
you're gonna isolate certain groups and
you're gonna treat them differently I I
I don't I can't sort of come to agree
with that myself I would because she
won't say it but I would give praise
here to Sally
Dame Sally Davis because in her time as
the chief medical officer in the UK she
fought incredibly hard to ship
health care in the UK from a
hospital-based
to a preventative to strengthen public
health to shift our behaviors into more
healthy eating reducing smoking and
taking more exercise and all of the
things that we know are good for us but
sometimes don't take on that I would
like to see that pushed further whether
it's I think incentives work better than
disincentives so I think as we come out
of kovaydin we learn the lessons for
public health and also pressures on
hospitals and almost every country in
the world is of course aging and the
demographic shift that's going on we've
got to rethink how we support public
health how we promote we support
prevention how we prevent the
comorbidities of diabetes obesity
strokes cardiovascular disease cancers
etc many of which are linked back to our
behaviors and I think that's going to
have to come through yes sir all of us
changing our behavior but also the
country putting incentives in place to
encourage to push it in those directions
and to help us make better choices so
that we eat less salt we less fat we
take more exercise and I think we're
going to have to rethink how we're
encouraging that happen and same Sally
did an amazing job at CMO and pushing
that agenda in the meeting or it will
get tame Sally's reaction down in a
moment or two a bit we've got another
question from our audience that will
feed into that and this one comes from a
medical student Iraq Shonda said avati
in Telford in Shropshire very good
evening to you Rach Shonda what would
you like to ask what can we do to me NHS
stronger right so what can we do to make
our NHS stronger well we have been
discussing that and Dame Sally Sir
Jeremy was saying and I remember
interviewing you just before you left
the job you talked about particularly
obesity but it is one thing for sure
that will strengthen the NHS is a
preventative strategy so let's start
with your
poling you've done during the week 43%
thought that it would be better the
health service afterwards and only 8%
worse and you know there are some
wonderful things going on it's not just
the response that these great staff and
all the key workers are making and we
now recognize it's not just doctors and
nurses the wonderful story and one of
the television programs when a cleaner
was asked what are you doing and he said
I'm reducing the risk of coronavirus I'm
part of this I mean they're doing a
great job but we're also seeing that
community care and GP care is now much
more digital we weren't getting there
before and then overnight time don't we
all like it it's much better it's much
easier to get your repeat prescriptions
because of digital there's so much
happening and what we've got to do is
bake all of that in because actually it
saves medical time so they can do other
things and we never have enough doctors
but it actually is better for patients
clearly we've got to start to put and
it's happening across the country page
ordinary patients or patients without
kovat back into the system we need to
know that they haven't got coded and
then get on with treating them and doing
the things they need and yes we are
going to as the Prime Minister's have
promised have to address obesity and
it's really complex as I said in my
former chief medical officer report
published on October the 8th unhealthy
food is in the spotlight and we live
particularly our children in this flood
of unhealthy food and we've got to kind
of down the flirt and take the spotlight
off and help families understand and
it's not easy I know maintain my weight
takes quite a lot of some determination
and I know how important it is for my
health but we've got to make healthy
choices the easy choices and in that
report I laid out what we have to do and
there's no one silver bullet
and exercise and biking matter or they
are not the Silver Bullet
it is calories in and we need exercise
too so I hope that we can look to a
renewed debate about this I know that
parents want their children to be
supported and protected and I think what
we're seeing with the comorbidities and
the story about how obesity doubles the
risk of death if you get comfort means
that others will want help but you can't
do it just by going home and starving
you have to be supported because this is
a lifestyle change that is not easy okay
another question our audience bursting
to ask them another question this time
from indigo Lonnie Lewis Jones who's in
Bridgend in South Wales indigo let's
hear your question please and good
evening hi hope you're all doing really
well have there been any new
technological advances due to the
increased research during the pandemic
that could be applied of the disease
diseases or viruses will there be new
information that can help the diagnosis
or treatment of conditions other than
Calvin 19
okay well have there been any new
advances and will there be any new
information so now and the future from
indigo so dr. Hamburg I mean have there
been or was it too early to tell even
for the rapid scientific research that's
been going on too early to see anything
that were perhaps helping in other areas
but but will there be could there be
absolutely and we are already seeing
some of it happen even though we're only
some four and a half months into our
experience with this new disease some of
it you were just hearing about a
professor named Sally Davies was talking
about digital health and you know really
developing both new tools and applying
in a more meaningful way existing
technologies to do telehealth and and at
a health at a distance care and that is
technology and
accordingly in the areas of medical
products testing drugs vaccines we're
seeing real innovation in the vaccine
area where we started off our discussion
this evening we are really thinking in
new ways and applying new approaches to
vaccine development and how to get the
immune system to respond in a protective
way against infection and some of the
vaccines that are in development are
novel vaccine strategies that have never
been used before and we're also starting
to rethink manufacturing to really
modernize it because sadly we have not
applied some of the available and
existing tools of advanced manufacturing
to areas in in biopharma we're also
seeing you know new types of drugs being
developed and we're seeing new
scientific technologies being applied in
diagnostic testing including genome
sequencing in fact it was the sequencing
of the genome by the Chinese and they're
posting it early in January that allowed
us to get quite a head start on on
development of new medical tools because
we knew what this virus was all of a
sudden at a level you know that was
quite profound and you know a decade
plus ago that would have simply been
impossible and we're seeing the
application now of gene editing to the
development of Diagnostics as well so
there's a lot of exciting harnessing of
existing science and technology and
really trying out new innovative
approaches as we seek to move as as
quickly as we can to finding better ways
to treat care for perhaps cure or
prevent this devastating disease dr.
Anne kanga song it would be very
interesting to hear the research that
the Africa Centers for Disease Control
is overseeing and do you see within that
research but
tensho for any spillover absolutely I
think I'm happy you bring that person up
before it could be nineteen pandemic
they were stopped one country on the
continent of fifty five member states
that was producing their dust that is
Moreau but as we speak today they are
these four countries on the continent
that I begin to develop Diagnostics for
public nineteen and I'm very convinced
that after the dis development many more
than Austin will show up and that is
more awkward Senegal Kenya and South
Africa I think this is what the
continent need have been the fact that
our were extremely challenged with
respect to access to diagnostic speaks
to the fact that the continent has to
engage in a very deliberate manner to
develop Diagnostics and engage the very
deliberate manner to begin to develop
and fund our research in vaccines and
clinical trial so I'm very positive that
optimistic that after the Kovach
nineteen is over many countries or
institutions on the continent will begin
to develop that capacity to produce the
gnostics so Jeremy your thoughts on that
what are you seeing what are you hopeful
about I think when you when you firstly
on the NHS I think when you come out of
crises like this it always it forces
everybody to reevaluate
you know what worked what didn't work
and what can you do to make an NHS
really functional for everybody and so
will face a choice to do that afterwards
on the science side I think my my most
hopeful thing which will also I'm quite
sure happen is that the interest in this
and it's you know it has captivated the
whole scientific world that will draw
into the whole area of infectious
diseases of vaccines of drug development
of immunology all of the things we have
to understand animal health ecology
social behavior psychology everything it
will draw another generation of young
people into that just as people were
drawn actually at the start
the HIV epidemic on and it was those
young people coming into science that
actually provided the answers in the end
to the HIV epidemic and it will be the
same with this pandemic as well when you
have something like this it galvanizes
people funding flows into it from
research agencies and young people come
into it and inevitably it's young people
the disrupt science and provide the
benefits for tomorrow and and I think
that's my most hopeful thing that I
think will come out of this and it is
really a very good reason to be hopeful
listen we got time I suspect for one
last question from our virtual audience
for this one we're going to Argentina
Mar del Plata Victor land olfi Victor
very good evening to you what would you
like to ask the panel hello everybody
considering that there has been some
kind of robust scientific coordination
to Terra Firma virus the question is
were there some some kind of global
agreement would be weak to deal with the
program or environmental ok
environmental pollution because we've
seen cooperation on collaboration on
this issue and dr. Hamburg that's
precisely what you were talking about
when we first started chatting so I
suppose if it were left to scientists
the immediate answer for Victor is yes
but of course when it comes to the
environment to the climate it's about
government's as well and that's a
different kettle of fish well that is
certainly the case that science and
politics don't always align in terms of
the identification of what needs to be
done and how best to do it but picking
up on Jeremy's hope in the future of
science and and broader participation I
hope that this pandemic will remind
people that science and evidence really
matters we have known for decades that
we were vulnerable to this kind of a
global pandemic it was not completely
unexpected that the gaps in our
preparedness and response
I think worse were you know more
expected but but we in a way with the
issues around climate change are seeing
a slow-motion pandemic unfold the
evidence is there we can see already the
impacts of of climate change in terms of
severe weather events extreme heat
episodes in terms of changing vectors of
disease in terms of damage to
agriculture and food and water supplies
the evidence is there about what is
worsening climate change and and what
are the accelerants and the evidence is
there about solutions that can make a
difference and even during this brief
period of of sheltering in place in the
reduction of many kinds of industries
car traffic and and other activities
that cause pollution we've seen you know
dramatic changes in air pollution in our
cities and and rejuvenation of aspects
of our environmental the context so I
hope we can learn people can understand
why science matters the critical role
that applying science and evidence to
meaningful sustainable solutions can
make and and that we will really
galvanize so that we can address clear
and present dangers and future owner
abilities in a much more lasting way
okay well Dame Sally I'd like your
broader views in a moment or two but
seeing as dr. Hamburg mentioned the the
mix of politics and science and perhaps
not going too well let me ask you about
your views of your immediate successor
Chris Witte and when he appears at those
those news conferences with the prime
minister and others some saying he's
being used as a bit of a human shield
well a scientific shield for the
politicians well I'm not on the inside
any longer so I can't judge I can tell
you he's a great doctor and I'm glad
he's there on all our behalf and for me
he's got the energy of someone 20 years
younger than me so none of us get
everything right I think okay well what
about the environmental aspects there
the fact that we've seen this
unprecedented level of rapid
collaboration can it be applied to
something like that I think we're all
learning from that I mean I'm enjoying
seeing some of the videos and actually
outside the birds the lack of asthma the
clean air the blue sky looks blue I
think that wakes us up to the problems
that there are from environmental
pollution I'm particularly interested in
pollution of our waterways with
antibiotics and other chemicals
particular otix and it's going to be a
hard slog to get change because not only
do we need international collaboration
but people have to sort out cope it and
then think so what as we come out of
COBIT can we do more and at the moment
collaboration is on other things well
sir jeremy of course cirque ovid has an
environmental linkage doesn't it given
we know it's come from animals
potentially from bats to humans and we
were talking earlier about these
zoonotic diseases yeah if you look back
over the last 25 years all of these in
all most or all of these emerging
infections have come from from animals
they've come because ecology is changing
the environment is changing the way that
humans animals interacts is changing
people are then now living in these huge
cities tens of millions of people and of
course those cities are now very
connected so that combination of
ecological environmental change animal
human interface big cities and travel
and trade that's what's driving this
21st century phenomena of these emerging
infections but if I could just broaden
it out a second and you look at the chip
the great health challenges
about the great challenges for Humanity
in the 21st century we can argue what
they are but but for me they would be
climate change and the impacts of that
they would be drug resistance which
again Sally has done such a lot for
throughout her career they would be
emerging infections they would be the
coming of the non communicable diseases
that John mentioned and of course mental
health and if you look at any of those
they're all going to need global
cooperation and collaboration because
there are no solutions to drug
resistance there are no solutions to
emerging infections there are no
solutions to climate change or mental
health without as working together and
as we come out of kovat 19 which we
eventually will the world is going to
face a choice as it has done after every
crisis whether war or epidemics or
plague in the past we're going to face a
choice do we come together as a world
and address these challenges together or
do we split ourselves into a polarized
world where we fighting each other and
we will face that choice and our
generation will have to make that choice
and I just hope we make the right one
that does the right things and brings
the world together rather than splitting
world apart and doctor in kanga song
fairly briefly if you were on that issue
of climate change from the African
perspective we already seeing what a
huge threat that is to the continent let
me perhaps just I'd be with what Jeremy
and the other panelists have said I
think being good property here is the
pathogen the population and the politics
with that politics with the risk not
working well I think where we see
absurd CDC and African Union Commission
we are saying there are forces that we
should take there one is the problem
secondly to coordinate our efforts then
collaborate and then to complete it I
think we are very very protective forces
very very seriously because without
coming together and solving our problems
collectively we will continue to be a
challenge these viruses I'm urging every
year over the first 30 years 30 new
pathogens have emerged there is no
challenge of when and another pathogen
to emerge we
currently fighting public 19 and not
interests of that in the next week or
the next one's there to come under a
virus will not emerge so I think it
really requires a absolute cooperation
and coordination this virus has taught
us that we are more interconnected as
the word that we thought we saw the
world emerge in China spread through
Europe United States and Africa so
within a spirit of less than four months
we are all affected by this virus and
the solution lies in coordination and
cooperation I think from where we fit in
Africa we strongly believe in that
partnership to in solving this is a
build up of them is requires a global
solution for okay well what what a great
message because we are almost out of
time is summer safe for tonight just
before we go I want to take a final
straw poll from our hard-working virtual
audience by a show of hands for the last
time this evening simply I just want to
ask you are you optimistic or
pessimistic about the future health of
the world after what you've heard this
evening hands up if you're optimistic
well well well isn't that heartening
well I'd say that's almost the whole
panel that's as fantastic to see so
tonight we've heard that we have to
assume that our powerful second wave of
the corona virus is coming and that it
won't go away until the population is
immune also that we can't assume we'll
ever have a vaccine for Cove in nineteen
but that the search for that and indeed
the future of humanity will require a
combined collaborative global efforts
well my thanks then to our panelists
tonight Sir Jeremy Farah
dr. Margaret Hamburg dr. John in kanga
song and professor Dame sorry Davis
thank you so much indeed for your input
on your expertise this evening and
thanks to of course to everyone in our
wonderful virtual studio audience thank
you all for taking part all your
questions a quick wave goodbye thank you
very much and thank
kewal at home for watching now tomorrow
night we end our week with special
programs about life after the pandemic
with a very special guest yeah I mean I
was lucky in my case and and and got
away with it quite likely but I've had
it and I cannot say Oh understand what
other people have gone through and you
can see that exclusive interview with
Prince Charles from or evening with his
reflections on coronavirus and the
future of life and society do join us
again for that eight o'clock tomorrow
[Music]